unune journée identique
vuvue du ciel. Mais des
cicirconstances plus heureuses.
A À 85 ans, l'Américaine
ShShirley Brooks-Jones revient
àà G Gander pour une 30e visite.
L Le 11 septembre 2001 est
prprobablement la meilleure choe
ququi lui soit arrivée.
(moteur d'avion)
C Ce jour-là, , la femme était
àà b bord du vol Delta 15,
vovoyageant de Francfort
àà A Atlanta. Elle faisait parte
dedes 6900 passagers coincés das
leles 38 avions qui avaient été
dédétournés vers Gander, l'espae
aéaérien américain étant fermé.
GaGander compte moins de
1010 000 habitants. Sa populatin
a a subitement presque doublé.
A Au mêmeme moment, Bill Hooper
trtravaillait à s son imprimeri.
I Il était aussi maire
dede Lewisporte, une petite vile
vovoisine de Gander, qui
a a accueilli 770 passagers.
EnEn moins de 24 heures,
lala communauté s'est mobilisée
popour les loger, les nourrir
etet les réconforter.
B Bill et Thelma Hooper
onont ouvert les portes
dede leur maison à t trois femm,
dodont Shirley Brooks-Jones.
T Thelma et Bill Hooper sont
dedevenus sa deuxièmeme famille.
S Shirley Brooks-Jones a changé
lala vie du couple et influencé
cecelle de centaines de jeunes
dudu coin. En guise d'héritage
etet de remerciement, elle a mis
susur pied une bourse d'études
popour contrer le décrochage
scscolaire, un problèmeme
dadans la région.
J Jusqu'ici, plus d'un million$
a a été amassé; 341 jeunes
enen ont bénéficié.
(m(moteur d'avion)
2 20 ans plus tard, elle débare
auau terminal de Gander, comme n
seseptembre 2001, sans vêtetemes
dede rechange : sa valise n'a ps
frfranchi toutes les escales.
CeCet agent de sécurité lui prot
dede lui apporter en main propre
àà L Lewisporte, dès s que poss.
S'S'il y a une chose qui n'a pas
chchangé en 20 ans ici, c'est bn
lala générosité des citoyens.
I Ici Maude Montembeault,
R Radio-Canada, Gander.